super important
watch the communicators monday night at
8 eastern on c-span 2.
next on american history tv a panel
discussion on the people's temple its
leader jim jones and the community
called jonestown he established in
guyana
in 1978 more than 900 americans died in
jonestown from cyanide poisoning in
what's commonly referred to as the
jonestown massacre
the panel includes two former members of
the people's temple and two authors of
books on the subject of jim jones and
the people's temple
the california historical society hosted
the discussion it's about an hour and a
half
i want to welcome you all to the
california historical society on behalf
of my board of trustees my incredible
team staff our volunteers all of our
members and all of our guests uh welcome
to your house of history for a very
special poignant and powerful afternoon
we are deeply honored to be a part
of our dear friends and partners
actually colluders
i think partnering is overused and i
actually like using colluders because it
has a little raciness and intent
at a san francisco public library you
cannot ask for better friends or
colluders and of course this is a very
special part of the one city one book
extravaganza
thanking susan goldstein marcia
schneider christina moretti and all your
colleagues for being so wonderful to
work with and allowing us to present
this incredible panel today
i want to give a special uh thanks and
remembrance to jim jones jr who would
have was very hopeful uh to be with us
today he sends you and especially the
panelists all his best but he wasn't was
unable to participate due to health
reasons so we'll send out some good love
to jim
the california historical society is
deeply honored
to hold the people's temple collection
at the decision of the guyana and
california court's
california historical society was chosen
as the repository
in 1983.
we have worked
tirelessly with many survivors and many
historians and playwrights and students
and people passionate to learn
what happened and how
over those past intervening years
and we are proud to be the largest
repository of archival materials
relating to the people's temple
and to jonestown
whether it be digitization of super
eight
films or over the over 50 different uh
collections contained within
the the people's temple uh broader
collection we're honored to steward it
and we invite you all in uh to research
it we're deeply honored that all of our
panelists uh have taken advantage um of
this collection and especially for our
members and supporters out there as well
as of course for our remarkable archival
staff uh this is the work that you help
us do
preserving whether they be fbi files or
photographs some of the last photographs
of course of many who we lost
in jonestown
your support enables our work
we're also honored to invite you after
the program and back to our library over
my right hand shoulder is the north
baker research library many of you have
used it it's the portal
to our remarkable collections
and jamie henderson on our staff here
has
lovingly laid out a number of
pieces from the collection
including a number of letters that david
used uh to write his book
so if you haven't
seen or touched that part of history
come back afterwards and hold history in
your hands it's
it's even i think more powerful
i'm honored to be here today and to
moderate the panel
i'm going to introduce
my wonderful colleagues up here and get
the conversation going
have them talk among themselves and then
take questions from all of you uh we're
deeply honored that c-span 2 is here
today we always like it when they're
here because you know we try and look a
little better under lights which means
we really can't see you guys that well
it's like you all look beautiful um
because you're mostly backlit so uh
to to best moderate and so uh and also
to help the uh question flow
uh you will have found little pencils my
those beautiful little sharp pencils are
something so cute about them and a blank
card so if you have questions
please feel free
to
jot one down
raise your hand discreetly like you're
bidding and one of my great team will
come and collect them and then i'll ask
them and what i've found in these for
those of you who have been to a
panel like that maybe at the
commonwealth club or here is that some
of the questions start to kind of lay
atop each other so we can um answer a
lot of questions i think uh in in good
time so
uh
i'm fir i'm going to introduce uh to
your right and to my left uh starting
with john cobb um john
is one of the few surviving
members of
the people's temple who's born into the
temple
and his family was part of the
of some of those very first pioneering
members who moved out from indianapolis
to redwood valley in california
and they were there of course for the
real beginnings of of reverend jones uh
attempt set at truly um establishing the
church
he was a member of course until the
group's tragic end in 1978 and he was in
georgetown with the basketball team and
jim jones jr at that time
he tragically lost 10 members of his
family and in jonestown and he is
currently writing a book about his story
and we are all wishing him well because
the completion date says 2016.
yes and it shall be
to john's
left and your right is
thrilled to welcome all these men and
especially marshall kilduff
who said he had the best commute ever
because he walked from the chronicle
building on fifth mission
and for those of you who know
marshall's long and illustrious decades
old career of writing mostly for the
chronicle but especially a very powerful
piece that was not accepted by the
chronicle in 1978
he has given voice
to
politics government or lack thereof
development city affairs
and has been one of the really
remarkable through lines of the san
francisco chronicle
as a native of san francisco and an s.i
guy
he matriculated from that lovely campus
on the old farm in palo alto and
and joins us
today
to i think at a great
depth of narrative
he author he co-authored suicide cult
history of people's temple and jim jones
next to marshall is david talbot
the man who wrote of course season of
the witch the one book
of the one read of the one city
and there could seem to be no more
fitting choice as as both the
generations
fade who actively remember
living here and being here in that
pretty horrible november of 1978
then david talbot's book
season of the witch which was published
uh in 2012 and has a deep resonance with
us still and of course is being read
widely uh this week
david uh is a american journalist that
we're honored to call our own here in
california
a trailblazer an entrepreneur he was the
founder and former ceo and
editor-in-chief of the one of the
world's first web magazine salon.com you
might have heard of it
um he figured out the web long before
anybody else uh due to sustained credit
and uh
you're in your are you wearing your
glasses on purpose look at you
when we talk later i'll take my glasses
okay he really has lovely eyes
and turned of course an idea into an
entire way to consume knowledge uh with
salon.com
and after leaving salon i increased his
reputation as a historian uh historians
like to think of journalists as just
faster writers than we are really
but we're welcoming him into the tribal
unit
he's just finished a book on called
brothers
on the kennedy brothers which i cannot
wait
to read
and he's also worked as an editor for
mother jones and writes prolifically for
time new yorker rolling stone and many
other publications
uh
last on the podium and certainly not
least
in terms of big heart and personality
and soul is eugene smith
eugene smith had just turned
21 years old
prior
to november 1978
and as he wrote and i'm going to read
his words because they're so beautiful
for all intent and purposes jonestown
was the forge that sealed me as well as
dictated my immediate future at that
time
my only responsibility then was to
survive there was no place to hide or
disappear
eugene lost his mother his wife and his
infant son that day
and he has i think spent the rest of his
life dedicated both to remembering and
and persevering as he said his
responsibility was to survive and bring
us knowledge from the depth of his heart
and memory
he turned to writing and obviously an
interesting
part of what we're gonna we'll talk
about today is how do you begin to write
about this whether from personal memory
or from journalistic or historian's
perspective
um and eugene's recent articles include
one for the joneson report
and he he's at work out of book two
i think 2016 is going to be a big year
fall okay we got spring it will be it
shall be you've heard it here uh at the
california historical society so uh
please join me in welcoming my four
incredible panelists
[Applause]
and
i think i'm going to just ask david
first to provide a brief historical
context uh as he's done so eloquently
you don't have two chapters of time dear
um but uh share with us kind of the
the you the the the time that um as you
so beautifully uh show us um really
starting in after the summer of love and
the rise of the counter culture
that helps us understand the uh the rise
of people's temple and of reverend jones
thank you yeah just a quick correction
by the way because all my books do kind
of blur together but my new book is the
devil's chess board and it's a history
of the dark uh uh the dark history of
the cia is there any
other as opposed to the light and
sunshiny unicorn yes exactly
uh sorry about that the context for
people's temple i think i think you
really have to look at
uh frankly some of what's going on in
the city already the social disruption
the redevelopment that tore out the
heart of
black san francisco
and that was the
the seed
the garden for jim jones
to establish his political roots in this
town and begin to i
have wide influence over the liberal
leadership of san francisco
but i don't think he could have done
that if the fillmore the western edition
hadn't first been largely hollowed out
by the likes of justin herman and the
san francisco redevelopment agency which
tore out the heart and soul of what was
once known as the harlem of the west a
very vibrant middle class
and lower middle class black community
nightclubs stores uh houses and so on
uh my own son joe talbot working with my
honorary son as i call him jimmy fales
is now making a movie that actually is
kind of
continuing that legacy or looking at the
legacy of that the last black man in san
francisco
so to this day you have a declining
african-american population that feels
very much sidelined pushed into the
corners in the city
and deep
and robbed of its political power
and that
definitely was the feeling at the time
when jim jones came here from ukiah
redwood valley
uh he was moving into a political vacuum
there were of course some
african-american churches there
but he became such a powerful
powerful force because he was a master
of manipulating people he was a master
and uh these gentlemen can tell you more
about that about finding out what a
politician's weaknesses were what his uh
turn-ons were and exploiting them and of
course he delivered bodies and votes
you know vote early vote often we can
talk about the election of 1975 as a key
turning point the mayor's race where
george moscone narrowly won
election
due to voter fraud i believe in in part
so
but i think you know very first and
foremost san francisco doing soul
searching has to analyze what it did to
the african-american community allowed
that redevelopment or negro removal as
james baldwin
called it later to happen and it was
into that
vacuum that jim jones moved
great yeah um thank you so much david
i'm i'm often reminded as some of you
who are my friends know
um of that wonderful james baldwin quote
that american history is longer larger
more beautiful and more terrible than
anything anyone has ever written about
it so
so in this context of
of the horrors and of urban renewal
especially as they were played out in
san francisco targeting first the
japanese american communities just had
come back from being incarcerated at
camp um
and then
simultaneously the african-american
communities
as well many of whom had moved in during
the war uh ironically to places held by
the japanese-american community so you
have this incredible cycle of
displacement
and in comes
a man with phenomenal charisma
charm and
power so
i'd like to ask with first john and then
eugene to share firsthand about their
experiences and their families
experiences with the church and helping
us better understand uh from their
perspectives so maybe john first okay
[Music]
hi everyone welcome uh first my ex my
experience isn't unique in that there
are
there are probably what one two other
people other than myself that
were born into people's temple that are
still living so
that's what i knew
from day one
and
all of the things that i've read so far
today most of the things i'll say
because i haven't read anything by any
means or most of the things we hear or
talk about has been factual things what
happened this date that dates so forth
jim jones and
what's been missed is there was a
day-to-day occurrence of people's lives
and how it functioned within people's
temple
day-to-day what happened not
not even jim jones just the people there
were several people
that actually made that temple function
um
towards its end
would have functioned perfectly without
jim jones even better
he had much
much to do with anything towards the end
he was just incapable of doing anything
but there's a whole story that's just
i've repeatedly seen that
what happened day to day in people's
temple what happened day to day in
jonestown how did people live
why people were there what really drove
people
there you know like there's a sense of
that people were like mindless people
following a cult and it and it was that
not that way of all at all um
many of the people that i know and
people that are still alive today are
very successful
and did not have a problem integrating
back into society because we were not
that much different at all
one of the things that it offered or
several things that it offered you know
a lot of people say it was involved
politically and that was a big driving
force for it
but i look at the same things happening
today
we're the same things that people are
voting for and looking for help with
education health care
housing being able to put food on your
kids table
once you become a member of people's
temple you don't have to worry about
that anymore you didn't and
your political beliefs of course
everyone wanted to make the world a
better place but those basic needs were
provided for you at some cost yes but uh
it's funny i've talked to a person that
i knew that her family was part of
people's temple
for quite a while probably about 20
years and she has a few kids and
grandkids now and i saw her a couple
years back and she said johnny boy
i sure wish there was something like
people simple now these kids today sure
need that structure or purpose
and granted there was a lot of terrible
things that happened but
the reason why people were there day to
day and what they accomplished what they
did the functionality how they live day
to day
i think has really been missed and part
of the things that has driven me to
write
is that the people that are no longer
with us
you know their story has never been told
you know
they've died and they've kind of been
labeled as people that were a casualty
of
wrong place the wrong time why were you
there
and
of course some of the people didn't want
to be there that'll a lot i'll expose a
lot of that on my book have they had the
choice to leave they would have
but all in all there was i think so much
more that was missed
to that whole story that's not been told
the negatives the craziness of jim jones
and so forth has been repeated endlessly
and i kind of feel that where we are in
our culture and our time people are
ready to hear okay well what else
happened there
you know other than the facts and the
untimely end of it and so uh
that's what's driven me to write and
that's where i'm at with it as far as my
story oh god it's long
like i said i was born i was born there
and so i had a different understanding
of it it was
it was uh
i saw it for what it really was behind
the scenes a lot of people came in and
saw jim jones as a prophet of what
hillary you name it i don't know god
whatever you might call it i never saw
him as that i never did a lot of the
things that he perpetrated that he could
do i
knew from pretty much day one he wasn't
doing those so i never
it's not why i was there while my family
was there you know my mother wanted a
better a better life for her kids we
moved from indianapolis you know against
my father's will he eventually followed
us
but um
so there were other reasons for it but
anyway basically that that's my story
that's my story i'm doing a pretty good
job of of telling and i think it'll be
very interesting it'll be a lot
different than what's out there so far
thank you john i'd love to come back to
some of that especially those those
missing stories of the day-to-day
community that was formed and the needs
that were met um and especially you're
right in the in the 70s when we all kind
of hoped we hoped we had hope except i
believed i actually believe we're all
created equal and you know
a crazy time exactly yeah thank you sir
eugene
well um
thanks everybody for being here i came
into the temple basically when i was 15
uh ninth grade the summer of ninth grade
coming in
um i'd always been politically inclined
because my mother was in addition to
that she was always searching for that
religion
so in detroit we were part of aretha
franklin's father's church we're part of
dr lofton's church
they had been catholic we had been
baptists we had been protestant we had
been non-denominational
so every six months it was a new
religion
um
i basically we revolted
roughly around 12 or 13 so i'm done with
it
um and she'd heard about jim jones so
you really should go hear him so i went
and heard him at at irwin junior high in
fresno
and i thought it was interesting the
sunglasses threw me off
this is in the moment by the way
and
i didn't really come back until i was 18
and then i moved directly into a commune
in san francisco at the temple i stayed
behind stage initially
for me the temple was a candy store in
the sense that there were no limits on
what i could do
there were no limits on who i could come
in contact with there's no limit to like
having
there was no end to my learning
um in seventh grade i was already
reading at a 12th grade level so coming
into people's temple at 18
them having a printing press having a
wood shop having a construction crew
having all these resources to get you
into the community to meet all these
different people it all seemed normal
and what made it seem so normal was is
that you see moscone adam at a meeting
or you see jerry brown i mean willie
brown at a meeting or you see jane fonda
in la or somewhere so well these people
can't be getting we're not all being
fooled
something about this has to be real or
so you assumed
um
and so what happens after a period of
time is is that as john alluded to
earlier
is that jim jones became background
noise and what you felt responsible for
were the other people that were there
they were your family
uh you felt responsible to them and a
lot of people stayed
because they don't want to leave their
family there alone
they don't want them to be abused or
possibly heard
or
interrogated because you left
so some people stayed out of guilt some
people stayed out of responsibility some
people stay out of love for other other
human beings
that they had no blood relationship with
but they felt entitled to protect them
to protect them and be at their call so
to speak and we never called
old people old people
we called them seniors
and they were the repository of
knowledge
when a elder person spoke you were
expected to listen if they needed
assistance you were expected to assist
during that time they passed on their
knowledge to us and we passed my
knowledge to the younger ones
jonestown was a little bit different
getting there was an adventure
being there was an adventure
and a lot of times you were working on
adrenaline
because you'd either had a white night
that you didn't know if it was real or
not
and even when you did know it was real
there was a certain urgency to it just
because you were being awakened out of a
dead sleep and running to the pavilion
to see what had happened were we being
were we under attack
were they gonna take the children were
they gonna were they gonna kill the
seniors were they just gonna bomb us off
the map and you know this never happened
even if you knew that
there was a certain fight
in my first night coming into jonestown
we're going through all these potholes
already wrote about it and these
potholes were just huge because it was
just red clay
and you couldn't see the jungle even
though the jungle is only 20 yards on
each side of you you could not see it it
was so black you could see what was in
front of you
and you could hear the pavilion miles
away
people yelling and screaming you can see
the lights up in the middle of a jungle
because it's right close to venezuela
which is why we were there uh ford's
burn of one that was disputed area
between venezuela and guyana and so by
having a religious community there or
agricultural mission justified diana
seizing that particular property
um the
jumping off that trailer
going to the pavilion seeing people you
hadn't seen for years or seeing people
that you had thought had left
but they hadn't
um seeing my wife who at that time was
just weeks away from delivering i hadn't
seen it probably in four months
i hadn't seen my mother in over two
years
friends i hadn't seen for longer than
that in some cases
so getting there acclimating
was easy
staying there acclimating was very
difficult
that's it
thank you
um
marshall you
you started
work probably in about 1976
but then
intensively it seems in about january of
1977
working as a reporter for the chronicle
investigating
people's temple church
[Music]
wanting to write about it for the
chronicle not accepted
by the chronicle
which david details very closely in
terms of how close the chronicle
editorial leadership was uh to jim jones
and then end up publishing i guess it i
think was it
1978 or march of 1777
publishing his uh uh his piece if you're
trying to get me fired you're doing a
very good job yeah
all right
let me just uh see you watching so talk
to us yeah i will anyway so let me just
let me try to strike a quick note of
contrast between these idyllic you know
idealism driven uh
kind of full enclosed uh life in the
church and the way it would look to you
or i or at least to a reporter
was nothing like that
this church was
hostile
very enclosed didn't want to really deal
with the world except on its very own
stricter strict and structured terms
uh it went everywhere on its own when
david mentions the western region being
flattened by redevelopment that's part
of the problem but the church came in as
a total unit they didn't do they did
some recruiting but they were by and
large themselves on buses coming from
redwood valley
it was not a totally homegrown or very
open really in many ways organization it
was especially true if you were a
reporter asking questions such jones
what are you up to next
can i look at your temple can i walk
around and meet your people it would be
very difficult
to be a casual uh joiner or inquirer or
for that matter a
historian like the california historical
society would want to be it it was a
very uh
very uh sort of circumscribed bounded
world that they lived in up
getting back to the chronicle uh yeah
they flattered the heck out of my boss
they invited him uh here's the western
edition don't you want to come to our
church we explain life to you
you know a new guy in the job would want
to know that and and be accepted and and
won over and he was so when i went to
the church finally after
many many efforts to get there up they
sat me in the front row right next to my
boss
and they said and so it was very clear
that the temple was
in charge of the deal and don't worry
about it but
that wasn't
so much my problem as
the aspects of the inside the church
that were the troubling part of the
whole story the stuff that david's
written about and i'm sure will be in
the books that these two guys are
writing about but that was
your life was really not your own uh in
many many ways that broke up families
all your money got turned over uh
if you're a woman you were at special
disadvantage put it delicately uh there
was a lot going on faith healing to win
over folks
it wasn't
always as idealistic and as and as kind
of forward-seeking as
many of the the ideals that
you would want to have and the thing as
this came out the church
basically ran away they went to guyana
because their time was up in san
francisco now you mentioned the
politicians that's a whole other world
this is a very complex story in a lot of
really interesting ways
the politicians saw what they wanted
they took what they wanted they were
pleased and then then when the whole
thing fell apart it was all i didn't
know that you can't blame me and
david gets in this big time in the book
but it's it's a whole other side of the
story this this absent-mindedness this
lack of history this forgetfulness this
choosing what you want to remember
to me is one of the worst parts about
this experience
you know there's there's no memorials in
san francisco to this thing um when the
body's remains were brought back from
guyana those that weren't claimed
are now in a uh kind of corner of an oak
cemetery what could be more distant you
know kind of disembodied just just
pulled away from the the story than that
uh
a lot of the politicos that uh you
mentioned gene are still hard at it and
uh
who's to say
they want to talk about this i doubt
very much and
that there's just a lot of names that
have gone through this story that for my
boy in my mind have not really had
counted for it
to put it politely and uh
i think the story in a way continues to
have kind of fingers into the very
very present
as david miss said also san francisco is
in a lot of tumult right now a different
kind the dates are different the dollar
signs are bigger the locations the the
nature of the quarrel but
you know could something like this
happen again could somebody show up with
an answer
could
uh
claims or or or vows of of
of future good things be taken at face
value never examined
could people be accepted on solely their
terms without a real without a critical
look i think those are
from my minds as a wise guy journalist
that's kind of what i look for in this
story and what i find
um is still
the people's temple itself the location
the four walls the property it's now us
post office i mean
you know it was a big federal
kind of story the first congressman the
only congressman ever killed in the line
of duty was leo ryan and jonestown
now the federal government owns the land
that
in a sense is bad guy killers came from
so it's
cheap irony maybe that's too simple but
this stuff is is buzzing around in many
different forms and fashions and um
that's my story
wow you have a lot more stories than
that but but thank thank you all all for
and i know you're all we're brimming
up here with thoughts and ideas as well
as in the audience and we'll continue
our conversation up here a bit more and
then turn to you
i am struck as an historian of this
remarkable confluence
of of course the legacies of slavery
institutional racism poverty
marginalization segregation jim crow
coming out of course of
the
powerful you know tumultuous time
first with world war one then world war
ii and the dramatic change in
demographies that you think of
california from about 1948
to 1978
and i always think that time somehow
here is has a multiplier right it's like
two years california time you know no
that's about 20 years somewhere else
everything seems to happen so fast and i
think the churning
social changes that
all of you lived through and many of you
in the audience lived through and some
of us were born into are manifest here
on the tip of this peninsula
you know it's not david writes very well
why someone like harvey milk or moscone
coming from a progressive
uh very progressive tradition or in
milk's case you know fighting tooth and
nail for recognition not only as a gay
man
but for a role
in governance of the city
that all of those took place
at that same time culminating in
in an opening i think really for someone
like jones uh to to move in but i what
i'm loving about the conversation so far
is this difference in perspective
that the yearning for community from
particularly from dislocated people to
whose lives were continuously ripped
apart
to find that um gina was struck by what
you said it was a candy store you had a
library you had all things that you'd
want as a kid you had a library woodshop
printing press get health care food
and i think that some of those basic
needs uh and then john what you said in
terms of
wouldn't it be nice if if that kids
growing up
in the mission or uh in really anywhere
in the bay area outside of pockets of
affluence didn't have to worry about
that every day
every minute of every day or their moms
didn't have to worry about it every
minute of every day so
in terms of how um
how the people's temple encompasses all
those stories the very personal
as well as the very political um
is i think some at the heart of what
we're hoping uh to present to all of you
today and you've already teed it up so
beautifully um
john i'd like to come back to you in
terms of some of the um the missing
stories and
and wanting to reclaim some of that past
that that followers weren't necessarily
mindless that they made their own
community within that
those spaces whether it was here
up in the redwoods or
down in guyana
would you talk a little bit more about
some of those stories and and those
people and what you what you remember
and what you'd like to yeah sure there's
there's there's many okay pick from
thousands yeah there's many i can just
i'll give you an example of a week
for instance a week in redwood valley
when i'm probably let's say 13 years 14
years old impressionable time yeah not
i'm not impressionable i was already
there
as a teenager but nicely but what you
have to understand is i saw jim jones as
i didn't see him as father as some
people called him i didn't see him as
all these spectacular things i saw him
as
a man i was i was we're family both of
his two of his sons married two of my
daughters we're brothers we're still
brothers to this day i lived in their
house half of the time i saw him behind
the scenes a lot of time so i wasn't as
apprehensive or
fearful of him i talked to him right on
a daily basis every other day or so so i
mean i was just acclimated to it to
where it was my lifestyle um
very different a great a good friend of
mine lives in atlanta he he he grew up
watching us he joined the temple when he
was 12 12 years old he was a foster kid
came to redwood valley and he said john
i was just
a lot of people thought you guys were
treated special but i was your friend
and you guys were held at such a high
regard and we were talking about our
schedule monday mornings started off
very sleepy and i'll tell you why in a
minute up in redwood valley go to school
of course do our regular things as a
student i was a three-star sports star
so i had practices after school very
busy
after that on a monday come back home do
more work probably hang out with jimmy
and steven and us and play a little more
ball
tuesdays same thing go to the church
homework studies
with
teachers who were members there had to
do that i had to keep a 3.0 gpa at a
young age always growing up and i didn't
know why i just had to so we were very
well educated a wednesday night same
thing we had meetings temple meetings
that lasted oh god until late i don't
whatever
you know
get up back to school thursday same
thing thursday tutoring at school
friday and thursday night games of
course friday
games again school homework in right
after our games we were not really
supposed to go to these games all the
time but our parents along with marcel
and my mother made sure we all had that
experience rush after our game suitcases
are packed get on the bus in redwood
valley
come to san francisco get to san
francisco after a couple two or three
hour ride
have a meeting friday night in san
francisco after the meeting friday night
in san francisco get back on the bus
go to l.a
arrive in l.a do a rest stop overnight
get to l.a saturday morning we all get
off the bus stay home to our friends in
ellie that we saw every couple every
other week or so play play some
basketball get something to eat services
saturday all night saturday save your
friends in l.a services sunday holiday
sunday get back on that bus drop off
people in san francisco get back to
redwood valley what about three in the
morning four sometimes sick rush off to
school everybody goes to work that was
my life
and that's what i knew and it was normal
to me
surprisingly it serviced me well as i
got older
very disciplined very able to march the
task but it was fun to ask because you
were not doing it by yourself you were
not doing it
being beaten to do it you were doing it
with hundreds of other people your own
age
they were your friends and so everything
that you did was fun it was fun to ride
to san francisco every week and it was
fun to go to l.a every weekend it was
fun to see all these places you know it
was
it was what we did at the same time it
kept us out of trouble
we saw a different lifestyle
where we being sometimes people thought
we were being programmed and beat down
at the same time
not one-on-one per se he had his
indoctrination he had his meetings or
whatnot
[Music]
i'm sure a lot of people were believing
that and listening to it but
we were not that there for that reason
we were there for a purpose with our
families to ultimately make it a better
world to have other people see the way
we lived
uh we didn't see color so forth and so
forth and and we treated other people
that way we we got friends outside of
people's temple
that uh you know i surprisingly am very
good friends with noun
that were never members so i it was uh
until i got older i didn't see what
other people were experiencing
of course all the other negatives and
all the bad things were documented i'm
sure in david's book i have not read it
and many of the other books and that was
a part of it
um i'm not trying to retell that story
i'm trying to tell a whole different
story of just what it was like
with life in the temple
yeah absolutely well and people's temple
was one of many communal
experiments
um
cesar chavez and laplas
[Music]
many people
and many historians listening to some of
the last tapes of his conversations
before his death was increasingly
insular
macracy has written a really brilliant
book about this increasingly paranoid
increasingly driven to he had his own
white knight version slightly different
but i think for so many who went through
a lot of the social justice movements in
the 60s they their worlds did close in
and what you saw marshall in that kind
of fortress people's temple
many people increasingly saw
um in in many movements and of course
california has an amazing history of
communal socialist other kind of
experiments uh
in communal living yeah i don't even cut
you off being a fortress i totally agree
with what marshall said
it being a fortress for a reporter or
whatnot of course
of course uh you were not you weren't
pervy until privy to a lot of things
unless you were a member yeah so once
you became a member
everything opened up to you you know i
had friends that went to school once we
came to san francisco that would come on
sundays and visit
um but you brought them in
they would come and visit on their own
they would say i want to come outside
yeah you're welcome
you
they're
coming
conduit too i would i would see them
come in but i wouldn't hang out with
them i was busy doing other things i
mean if you wanted to come you could
walk in the door and come it wasn't like
you had to be a member to get in no if
you wanted to be a reporter and come in
and get a story that's a whole different
thing right but if you just wanted to
walk in off the street come to a service
you're welcome to come in you know
so yeah um does that answer your
question yeah i know that's very helpful
either the
john eugene and that is when you see or
hear of other religious groups movements
uh causes that strike people in in an
exciting new way
do you kind of wince do you worry do you
think anything of it or does it seem
not a lesson that you need to uh
to learn or to talk about i my concern
is that so much of this is repeatable
and in a way kind of familiar an outline
by talking about it by writing about it
by speaking as we are today
does that get people a little more aware
of their world or i don't know that it
does i think when people have their
minds made up to believe in something
they're going to do it
uh regardless i just that's just people
that's instinct you know so much for
journalism right there yeah all right
well you know i don't know i've seen
people that are in other groups and
things and and i can look at them and
just shake my head but you can't tell
them nothing they're going to have to go
through that and find it out
for themselves you know i i would say
that any group for anyone out there that
takes any of your
rights away you know that you can't do
this or you can't when they start saying
you can't do this can't do it
that's that's flags to go up right there
no you know if you don't have the right
to go to a traditional type group
church whether it be whatever you go on
sundays if you want don't go on
saturdays once they start laying down
all these rules that you have to abide
for that's no longer a church you know
you take your rights away that's that
crosses the line and that was one of the
many problems there yeah you know eugene
what do you think about marshall's
question it's
it it's complicated because the the
temple had a lot of facets
like
jimmy i mean excuse me john was still in
school i was i had just graduated from
high school when i moved up to the uh to
san francisco so my day was a lot
different
uh my day was typically started at 5 00
a.m
by 6 a.m i was already in the back
parking lot and i was on a construction
crew in fact i was in charge of the
construction crew
so
in san francisco we'd be building crates
to send equipment over to guyana be it
jonestown or georgetown and those crates
if you could imagine
the materials for a thousand people
what had to be packed up organized and
shipped it was phenomenal we took years
um when i was on construction in in los
angeles was completely different
the day would start probably at 4 30 or
5 would be on the job site at 6.
um what we were doing then is
refurbishing homes that had been donated
by members
either we were either refurbishing the
homes
or we were remodeling the homes or we
were preparing them for sale and there
were literally hundreds of homes
and so the the work day would work well
until nine ten eleven o'clock and be
expected to get up at five have your
breakfast by 5 30 on the job site by 6.
now if there was a meeting in san
francisco we would leave friday night to
be in san francisco by saturday morning
we didn't work on saturday
we didn't work on sunday but coming back
to get to l.a and we'd leave we'd leave
uh san francisco what
nine ten o'clock on sunday nights
get back to la that morning
get direct into your work clothes and go
to work
um and vice versa
and so it was a very involved
environment a very pushed environment
in terms of people coming freely or
coming to meetings
that happened on occasion but a lot of
times they were stopped at the door and
i know this because i was on security at
one time as well
and
it would be all you know this is a
members night wednesday nights were
always for members only
and those nights would be different than
any other night uh saturday saturday
nights were for was open services
and people were invited to come in you
would be searched
uh sometimes a person might be assigned
to you to see who you what you were
about
um
who brought you there who suggested you
come to who would vouch for you
if no one vouched for you you just came
in cold turkey so be it
um
there was always a
a line that was followed it might not be
the line that you felt was correct
and sometimes you would let it go
because you felt that the end justifies
the means
i'm not saying that i agree with that or
i think it was right but that was the
moment
the other thing was
is that when new members came as in
myself and i moved to the temple
i was observed for a long time in fact
my first day i was called up to the
third floor in san francisco and that
was where the family stayed john you
stayed up there right
yeah so i was called to the third floor
uh
maria casarez and because look eugene uh
you're not gonna be you're not gonna be
running through all these girls you're
not gonna be having all these
girlfriends you're not gonna be doing
all of this you know you're gonna work
for the cause you're gonna be a
socialist you know your life has just
changed
and sure enough it did
it it did change in a lot of ways
some things i kept
the majority of it i threw away
what i did keep though was perseverance
and focus
in that no matter what i do for the
remainder of my life i will always be
associated with
jonestown people's temple jim jones my
name will always be associated with that
so therefore the burden for me is always
set an example
all the time
there is never an off day
um initially coming back to the u.s was
just
horrendous because we were on the news
we were in the paper we're in magazines
and we're all considered crazies and and
that wasn't the case
people's temple did not attract ignorant
people
it just did not
yeah
can i if i could follow up there and
they
you know that's my experience from the
interviews i've done and obviously
eugene and john know many many more
people who are involved in the temple
than i do and who i interviewed but
every one of the people i interviewed
actually uh who went through people's
temple were incredibly bright uh were
incredibly uh
politically sophisticated
um it was you know
for me very enlightening look i i grew
up at the same time you know and i lived
communally i was very politically active
i was active in the prisoner rights
movement when i was in college in santa
cruz we were involved in the soledad
brother movement with george jackson
uh i was so i was you know working with
the black panthers i
i understood that
power of working together and having a
political vision and wanting to uh
change uh so much of what was wrong
about american society
but as i write in the book at a certain
point
these visionary movements
because we were losing our leaders not
just because of our own fault
leaders were being assassinated the war
in vietnam kept grinding on
the racial situation in our inner cities
was getting worse and worse there was a
poison leeching into america's soul and
that's the way it felt to me as a young
person a young activist at the time and
there was a desperation as we lost one
leader after the next martin bobby jfk
malcolm
for new leadership who could step in and
take us to the next
level
and that was definitely the feeling here
when jim jones came to san francisco a
lot of people sized him up as a
charlaine right away and if you read his
uh you know i know john you're in the
inner circle in the family but as a sort
of an observer outside if you read his
correspondence how at one point he's
endorsing nixon for president 68 and
he's writing fawning letters to
kissinger and then he does a flip-flop
here when he comes to liberal san
francisco and he's courting liberals as
if he's you know the second coming of uh
you know bobby seal uh
you know
there was a a a i think a cynicism there
uh that he was practicing i don't think
you and i don't think many most of the
people in his movement were cynical i
think you were responding to real needs
and when you two described what it felt
like to be young people in that world it
does feel very uh warm and embracing and
it's taking care of the basic human
needs as you were saying that society
should be taken care of and to this day
america hasn't figured that out and it's
some in some ways even worse as we know
with the black lives matter movement the
police violence and so on so i totally
understand what the attraction was and
what it must have felt like for a young
person in some ways living in that
communal environment that took care of
basic needs
but at some point there was a corruption
that set in at the top whether jim
was getting into drugs too much that's
what jim his jim jr told me when i
talked to him he saw the drugs becoming
a bigger and bigger influence on jim
senior
and by the time he got here there was a
kind of bubble mentality i think that
marshall is referred to a kind of
fortress mentality you know i
interviewed cleve jones the gay activist
who worked closely with harvey milk at
the time
and harvey was also cynically using jim
jones because there was a it was a
two-way street for his votes and his
support and he said he would send cleve
over the people's temple and say you
know here uh you know pick up some
posters or or get something there he
goes but don't talk to anyone be careful
they tape everything you say at the same
time harvey milk was very and he says
they're all crazy meaning their
leadership there at the same time harvey
milk is saying that there's letters
right here uh in the files that i used
when i was doing my book of harvey later
when people's temple went to guyana
where he's writing to joe califano jimmy
carter's uh
secretary of health saying you know
don't cut off the social security checks
that basically jim jones was stealing to
fund the operation because this is a
beautiful retirement community um
so he knew differently but the
politicians were
taking advantage
of of of what jim jones could deliver
and jim jones was delivering all sorts
of things he was you know according to
other people i talked to uh he was
delivering women to
uh you know george moscone he knew what
george moscone's tapes were in women
and so again there was a corruption that
was setting in not only within the
church but that corruption began to seep
out throughout the liberal leadership in
san francisco and everyone was
implicated willie brown dianne feinstein
you know uh right on down the line
yeah so so i think we have to separate
what the dream was what it what how it
did take care of people to a certain
extent but we also have to be honest
about the corruption that did set in
there at some point
several people have written it i'm sure
you have in your book i'm sure you've
documented it very well that has been
over and over and over again you know
and rightfully so and i don't dispute
any of it um
he he would use whatever platform he
needed to get what he wanted he was a
master of that he could
tell you what you wanted to feel and
believe and have you believe in it and
he was a master at that you know so uh
oh for sure
you know and i'm not i'm not trying to
take away from that you know i'm getting
older in age and at one time i was one
of the youngest surviving members and
now i'm 55. you know um so
we're all getting older and so i just
feel there's a side of this story that
people
people uh
writers and whatnot did not research who
cares about what happened day to day day
to day what happened from this further
20 years of it uh within the
organization how did the people interact
how did that get built jim jones didn't
do any of that jim jones his hands were
as soft as a baby
okay
and and a lot of a lot of spectacular
things got
accomplished throughout that group it
was it was very well named people's
temple tor you were right he was heavily
dependent upon drugs you know i was with
him for the last year of his life every
day me and his sons we were his personal
aides and he was just drugged out he was
totally gone once jim jones found out
when his advisors charles gary and
others came from the u.s to tell him he
could no ever never again leave
jonestown his life was over
he told us he cried to us and told us he
would plead and bake be in the radio
room at nights he talked gene and
everyone can i and finally it got to the
point i said jim you can't even go to
georgetown anymore
once you leave jonestown you could be
arrested
and once that sunk into him he turned to
drugs full time and he was pretty
useless we pretty much had to hold him
when he walked we had to zip his pants
you know so in those latter
months
he was out of sight sometimes and when
he came to talk it would be just just
what the hell are you talking about you
know he'd be rhetoric and he would think
of something crazy to talk about to try
to make something when there was nothing
to talk about you have to understand
when he got over there there was no more
need for fake healings
there was no more needs for offerings he
took offerings every hour seemed like uh
there's no more need for trips there was
no for a need for him to grandstand it
was time for all hands on deck we got
crops to plant and cattle to herd and
houses to build and paint irrigation
that we need you know for the first few
months we had no power
the biggest thing that happened over
there is when the generator came we all
had power you know we all live with
wikis at night walking around a little
wiki carousing candles in the jungle in
the jungle no lights i mean it's like
jean said you couldn't see your hand it
was so pissed dark imagine that so i
mean there was a lot going on that he
had nothing to do with see all these
things aren't told so if all these
amazing things are happening who was
doing it
not him
you know and those are the things that
i'm talking more about not to take
anything negative away from jim jones he
was oh god all the bad things that more
people have written
true and then some i would never take
anything from that but there's also a
whole another side of the story of a lot
of amazing people that i grew up with
and knew for 18 years from my whole life
that made that thing
transpire
could have possibly without jim jones
succeeded very well
some of us discussed that and how to get
a rid of him in detail and almost got to
that point at one time
and we had to say no we what would we do
if we did this guys you know it got that
serious you know i mean thinking ahead
hindsight is 20 20 had that whole thing
been able to go on even you know a lot
of people liked staying in uh jonestown
half the people did my own sister my
eldest sister told me personally she
didn't want to be there anymore she only
stayed because of us her younger
brothers and sisters
and she wanted to do other she wanted to
stay within the organization but she
wanted to be doing it stateside and
doing everything and doing other things
as did many people may i ask john and
eugene a question that i never was able
to figure out when i was doing the
research and this uh i hope it's not too
traumatic a question but one of the
things i did was listen to the fbi i
guess the fbi got hold the tape the
final the final tape
which is chilling obviously chills your
soul to listen to it and i still you
know
uh just shut her thinking about it uh
what's on that tape but there's an
amazing woman
christine miller
who stands up to him at one point and i
write about this in the book and she's
the one at least on the tape that i
heard woman who confronts him and says
no no no let's think about the children
here let's not do what you're about to
you know what about russia tell us to do
and it sort of at one point she seems to
actually have people coming to her side
she's such a
forceful passionate woman and her
argument is so strong but then uh
someone stands up and starts to shame
her who turns out to be an ex-boyfriend
someone told me of hers
okay and so famous of the mind of sharon
so she loses her momentum and at that
point it's the power shifts back to jim
jones and but it's you know it's like
one of those what ifs that is again just
uh you know you makes you shudder to
think what if she had been able to
persuade the crowd so my question is why
don't you think more people in that
crowd that night did respond to
christine's pleas and say you know we've
gotta you know this is madness we can't
go through with this it's quite simple
okay it's very simple in fact any any
man young man that would have stood up
that would have challenged him
that would have supported her were gone
the basketball team was gone
i was already in georgetown during
importing
um anybody that would have been any
challenge to him publicly
were gone
yeah there was no one there was no one
there to take up the mantle
and just to bring us into perspective
there were meetings before that
you know in the early summer
early like in july august as well as
march and april
where other members challenged jones on
different things in meetings you know
there in jonestown it just happened that
was the last meeting
but anyone that could have challenged
him
or been able to control him they were
gone do you think he timed it for that
reason because you were all gone i think
i don't know so much that he timed it i
know that the timing for
congressman ryan and that group could
not happen at the worst time and i don't
mean it should have happened they should
have been allowed access
anytime they wanted to but it happened
at a time to like eugene is saying
any people that would have stood up to
jim jones and had people follow him were
not there and we always will carry that
for the rest of our lives and that is so
true uh interesting story uh
stephanie my niece who's
doing well lives in new york the only
reason she's alive is that we were
leaving people left there all the time
you know if for whatever reason the boat
going eugene worked in town a lot of
people left all the time people weren't
just kept in like a concentration camp
like
many people may have thought or said
but that particular time we were all
leaving
i'd never heard that place that quiet
ever in my life it was you could hear a
pin drop and everyone stopped working
whether they were in the field or in the
carpenter shop or whatever it's like all
900 people came to just tell us goodbye
and we were happy to be going we're
going to go play basketball something we
were pretty good at and wanted to do and
we're happy and everybody's looks like
they're like ready to cry and we're like
what's up you guys bye bye bye
and my eldest sister ava just came up to
me and says take stephanie
and i'm like oh come on ava we don't
want to take we're going to have fun
she's like you guys just take her i feel
better at her being out here you guys
are gone stephanie's alive today because
of that she has a beautiful daughter our
niece katherine who's going to mills
college who's is alive because of that
decision
and ava just just it was a feeling there
that wait a minute because there were
one or two of us would leave some of us
would some of us would leave for
whatever jimmy liked to be in town
because he preferred being in town he
didn't like being in jonestown you know
um
and town and town was georgetown the
capital it was a city as opposed to the
jungle jonestown but uh it none of us
were anyone who would have stood up to
jim jones that knew jim jones that other
people felt safe would
that were close to us we were all gone
it was part of that quietness that left
people came to say goodbye to you
because they did have a premonition so i
don't think of the premonition i just
think they just they just they just they
just kind of felt like oh god who's
going to handle jim jones now you guys
are all gone what the heck you know i
mean
hold on a second because they could see
people just felt more comfortable around
all of us around being there knowing and
they saw us oppose him i mean steven
argued with him openly several times
yeah and and we realized stephen come on
we know you're right and we'd be the
mediators and people saw that just that
distension going on i mean even when he
asked us to come back before it got to
that point over the radio we told him no
we're having fun we're doing good why
should we have to come back
had we known that would happen we would
have gladly gone back we went i don't
know if anyone's read about this because
like i said i haven't read a lot of the
books but at the time this all happened
uh tim jones and myself went to the
police station
and talked to the police chief to see
what was going on and he kept us waiting
he came in and said you know we've heard
there's been shots fired
do you think something could be going on
and we were like yes there could be get
us there right away please get us here
get a helicopter there right away and he
left we never saw him again you know so
like i said she christine stood up she
didn't have enough people to follow her
and
once he once and a lot of people think
that there was mass suicides murders
whatever most people were killed or
forced to die a lot of people had such a
devotion to each other and i don't know
how people feel about this he could be
right or wrong that if
your kid was over a lot of the kids get
together in the nursery or the younger
kids get together and if one of your
kids died
a lot of people aren't going to leave
their family there right or wrong they
just weren't so were some people forced
to die probably but
i think more people that were forced
that did because once you see your loved
one you're not going to walk away and
leave them and i believe that
at least for my family i do i know for a
fact
one of the people who got away
and she's written a book i won't mention
her name she was like sisters with my
sister and she told me she told my
sister she was leaving we're getting out
of here we're going to the jungle and
she kissed her and hugged and said
goodbye i can't leave my family
you know so yeah the torture of that
yeah eugene and then we'll get to some
of these great questions but thank you
all i want people to understand that
when they said they were going to the
jungle
understand that this was a triple canopy
jungle in the daytime it was dark
at the night at night you could not see
your hand
there were howler monkeys there were
poison frogs anything that was brightly
colored was probably poisonous it was a
plant of some type
there's all kinds of species of
ants going into that jungle at night
with you running there for safety
imagine what you had to be scared of
i need y'all to understand that this
this jungle was not friendly at the in
the daytime
but alone at night
and
and if you didn't have a full moon even
when you came into opening you couldn't
see anything
please darkness thank you thank you both
and thank all four of you i have a
series of really interesting questions
i'm going to
telescope out a little bit and uh
perhaps
for marshall and david but as well for
john and eugene
uh one of our guests wants to know to
what degree did the average san
franciscan know of or experience the
people's temple and in what and in what
ways
could you could you repeat that sure
if you buy david's book uh
yes and it it will be for sale and he
will sign them yeah that's one of my
biggest complaints is there's no
yeah and how would it be done
appropriately fairly honestly tastefully
uh there's no marking of time that
there's so little history consciousness
about not just this event but many i
like it i mean moscone there's
an awareness that happened but what what
would really happen how did it work out
today i heard on the radio 35th
anniversary of dan white uh suicide i
mean yeah today uh but moving back to
the original reason we're here i i don't
as i said
believe there's much consciousness about
something as as
as as meaningful as this
i mean bad news is not something you
want to go back over it's it's not like
the end of world war ii it's not like
some some happy occasion that that marks
a dark chapter's end it's
it's that chapter it doesn't really have
maybe
the social lift or the inspiration but
as you can tell it's a very complex
thing there's so many strands personal
political uh social what was going on at
the time what do we feel about those
times now it's really an interesting
story and yet i don't know that there's
really much awareness yeah marshall
though i think take us back to those
years they have what did what did past
tense the average sun san franciscan at
the time so take us to 1977. what do you
think they knew
about this about people's temple and jim
i think they were pretty confused uh
there might be some awareness that the
group was a political force certainly in
in city hall's kind of wavelength
he was on the housing authority he came
to meetings with big group of people
about the same size as this group i
might add that's about how
light light he traveled
uh a couple of buses would pull up he'd
get out he'd show up he'd run the
meeting
there'd be enormous thunderous clapping
for
the approval of the minutes i mean that
this guy ran the show and i i think that
was at one level uh
there were news stories towards
77 78 about uh his influence questions
about his background
but as as david said people even his
allies knew there was something off
about the guy in terms of how they dealt
with him
milk's example is one i mean milk was a
big fan
publicly but
before during and after uh i'm sure he
knew better
and there were others
equal-sized names
walking the landscape now willie brown
and jerry brown who took part in it all
too
kind of saw the dark side but but went
along with it and i and i think uh to
their regret but one of our part of it
is is that the chronicle wasn't doing
its job and marshall is the you know
best person to testify about that i
write about in the book uh he was trying
to do his job his report and he finally
found a way to get that story out but as
we talked about steve gavin i think his
name was the city editor
because he was
compromised by jones was basically
spiking stories so you know the city
wasn't getting the proper information it
had because people were being uh
compromised uh people in politics here
and in media and you know
today we can have a whole other
discussion about is the city gain that
all the information needs the city is
going through its own you know great
agonies now of eviction and displacement
and i still don't think we have the
information loop we we need to have in
this city we don't have the political
leadership that's really uh addressing
those issues so there's nothing that uh
you know new
here and finally i want to say you know
there was though this sort of radical
chic syndrome at the time i just i do a
lot of speaking around town and people
come up to me and have their own stories
uh to tell which are always interesting
and a woman came up to me the other
night and said you know my mom was this
kind of crazy liberal and i loved her
you know but she was a free spirit and
she took me as a little girl to people's
temple means she was white you know
white uh sort of lefty uh you know san
francisco bohemian type and i think in
those circles you know jim jones and the
people's temple was seen as really cool
i mean because it was integrated it was
integrated and it was progressive and
they had great music and i'm sure you
know a lot of the church services were
wonderful experiences so
uh if you weren't a reporter snooping
around like marshall and was gonna get
the heave-ho
uh you know a lot of people felt welcome
there and felt that this was part of
something like you know like glide
church today that they want to be part
of the professor of history over at usf
not to i think his name is harris i'm
not sure if that's his last name he did
a speech over at uc berkeley and he said
for back in the 70s 60s 70s if you were
black in america people's temple was
really the best place for you to be as
far as opportunity
i'm sorry that was you i'm i'm terrible
with names man i'm sorry
and i agreed with you i agree with you
though and you know for the as far as
the opportunity
that it offered and and and elaborating
on what he said about the political
figures it's funny jimmy and i when we
came back in 78 79 and we bumped into
woolly brown and the welt and the uh
fillmore and he still knows us he'd be
like hey johnny jimmy jr and that's all
he had to say we're like what the [ __ ]
you were there all the time now this and
then he's he takes off in his mercedes
and he's gone we're like okay good
one of the questions
one of the things i didn't apologize at
all about it i mean i interviewed about
it you know no apologies well one of the
questions from the audience is what more
can be done to bring accountability to
political figures like the brothers
brown as they like to call themselves
and feinstein
one more time
one of the questions from the audience
is what what more can be done to bring
accountability to political figures like
willie brown jerry brown and dianne
feinstein i mean everybody's heard the
word untouchable
i mean
i mean these people have been in these
positions for three decades now
it'd be difficult if not impossible to
make them feel any remorse
or responsibility for what they did 30
years ago
um
and i have to say any person that thinks
the same way they thought 30 years ago
is not growing up
so so hopefully they're not the same
person they were or support the same
things that supported 30 years ago
um
another thing though
is that i
people's temple did not attract ignorant
people
so in terms of finding things on people
or compromising politicians or whatever
there were people that came in that
joined the temple and knew how to do
that
you know this wasn't jim jones working
in a vacuum all by himself like the
genius mad scientist or anything
um
yeah i mean there were there were there
were people who were gifted at whatever
they were gifted at and those those
tools were exploited
we have four questions on religion that
i think i'm going to weave together um
into one
um
there's there's one in particular about
the doctrine of people's temple and i
think
that's a that's a it's a big
conversation probably spend an hour on
that but i think you've gotten enough of
the flavor
of its commitment to social justice and
providing needs and to having a
full kind of community
the socialism aspect the socialist
aspect was was huge this was a long
kind of continuous interesting training
which i think jones picked up and as
well as the leadership in the church uh
picked up on a very rich tradition both
from the black churches as well as from
the progressive
churches of the united states i really
kind of post second grade awakening in
the 1840s and it was a really potent
stew
i think a very um both kind of spiritual
but also socially very liberal and
progressive
but the questions i think are
interesting um
the
one wants to know kind of how much was
religion a part of the daily existence i
think with the weekly existence
obviously and then others were how
um
[Music]
how the people's temple experience i'm
thinking through and then after
uh
jonestown
in november of 78 how did it change
religion
and
in san francisco so i think there's a
number of questions about religion um
so
did it change
did it change religion in san francisco
while it was happening and then the
aftermath and then um a little bit about
kind of religion in the life of the
church yeah speak to some of that thank
you it depends on when you joined
people's temple
if you joined in the
late 60s early 70s it was it was a
religious base
fundamentalism with healing
if you joined in the
72-75 it was a social movement
okay
if you join between 75 in the end day
it was about getting away from this
racist oppressive system this capitalism
gone wild
so depending when you came in the temple
dictated how you responded or what you
heard or didn't hear
if you came in with a fundamentalist
belief that
healer is healed and he is an
incarnation
that's what's that's what you stuck with
because that's what drew you
it was about political causes when you
came in
that's what you heard that's what kept
you there it was about getting away from
the u.s or getting away from capitalism
moving to a socialist country that's all
you heard
and you dealt with that you didn't hear
any of the other stuff because it was
all it was all background noise that was
that was for other people you knew why
you were there
very well
i think at some point it depend on how
his po once he saw his power grow and
how far how much he could get away with
his indoctrination had changed and what
he spoke about changed i would hear him
at home preparing what he would say day
to day and
and he would go from talking about
religion to social issues what not what
not to i am god and once he saw people
say yes he went crazy after that it
changed it changed fast yeah but
and thank you both on the periodization
i think is very powerful um marshall and
and
david in terms of how
the people's temple in jonestown changed
the
the the face of religion or the practice
of religion
uh and faith in san francisco do you
have any thoughts on that
because david you chronicle of course
the demise of the irish catholic machine
if you will early on in the book
and the clashes that that brought but
well i i think the interesting one the
interesting things was the
relationship between jim jones and the
other uh african-american pastors and
the ministers in in the area
i think you know you again eugene and
john can probably talk much uh more
informed about this than i am but i did
uh
find out some interesting stories about
the tensions between the churches
it seemed to me on the one hand you know
uh
the people's temple was delivering more
than the african-american churches had
that had been there for some time in
some ways you know in terms of providing
social services uh to the community so
there again that's one reason why
people's temple was able to sink roots
in this wounded community this hollowed
out community uh because they were
coming through more they were it was
more there was more energy there uh
people's temple was more mobilized
politically um there was more a sense
that they could do something for you you
know if you lived in the film or the
western edition i think and so there was
some resentment on the part of other
african-american churches and ministers
about this upstart who had just moved in
and hey he's white you know i mean that
was weird wasn't it i mean i think for a
lot of the african-american religious
leadership and yet some worked out
accommodations with him and so they then
became also i think compromise later on
as well some of the african-american
churches uh in in the community you know
that matches that matches what i what
i've turned up too uh there was a
resentment a new guy in town uh and he
did
as i said bring a lot of his own people
but obviously there was some some
recruiting some
some enlarging of the flock that he
needed to do here and
you know he would
pay bills at other churches he would
flatter them with
letters and uh calls he would
do his best to insinuate himself at the
same time
taking 10 or 20 old ladies
back to his church when he could uh
it was a
you know
a very skillful marketing job and he he
was very tough-minded about this as as
far as what
the the explosion of the church that
the end game whatever happened
diminishing the role of religion in san
francisco boy that's a big topic and i i
i would hesitate to play reverend here
and say that i knew what
long-term effect
uh people's temple had on religious life
in in the larger san francisco i
i like to think not a hell of a lot just
because of the kind of
downbeat kind of history we're reciting
here but um
i'm sure i'm sure it made a lot of
people cynical and doubtful about
religious leaders for a while
eugene why don't you you had your hand
up for a bit and then we're going to
give you the last word and then some
questions i didn't get to i'm sorry but
i know these lovely gentlemen will stay
around um and i want to course
re-welcome you to uh back to our library
to see some of our people's temple
collection including the letters some of
the toys made from the workshop
the reverend jones robe is out
some pretty powerful artifacts so eugene
and then uh deep thanks all around yeah
in terms of the african-american
ministers in the fillmore and throughout
san francisco in general i think the
issue was this is that you have a white
man coming to town
he's bringing 12 buses
70 to 170 to 100 people for bus because
when we rode on a bus
you sit in all the seats you sat down
the aisle and there was no luggage up
top all the kids climbed up top
so you had 100 people on those buses at
any one time
you got that coming to town
he's getting
accommodations that these ministers have
asked for forever did not ever get
he's having conversations that they've
always wanted and could not get
he's getting he's cutting deals that
they asked for the same exact deal and
couldn't get it
and at the same time
they're having trouble keeping their
memories because this guy over here jim
jones is not only poaching
their members but he's giving them a
reason to leave
right in in in the in the in play is not
not only did he poach them
not only did he get accommodation but
then he gets then he's on the housing
commission yeah which which dictates
which is a powerful position in san
francisco
that that's a lot of patronage exactly
when i came back and i started going to
school going to college i you know i was
kind of like i don't want to talk about
i hope nobody recognizes me so many kids
that i met my age 18 19 years old i mean
50 at least knew about the church it's
like oh my god my parents wanted me to
go there i mean in the bay area it was
like so many young people knew about it
and their parents wanted them there it's
just that when this man's great article
came out it was just like and it was a
good article i thank you about it thank
you for that it was very much needed but
it just and it was funny when the
article came out i was like what article
all i heard it was your name marshall
wrote an article everybody all kind of
hell broke loose i never saw the article
about a year later i said oh this
article you know
well i want to thank all of you
in the audience and
my
four amazing panelists delving into
these subjects i think is the very work
that the california historical society
is honored to do
uh
they're complicated and layered and
powerful uh there's no one simple easy
answer uh but between and among these
four amazing souls i think we've had a a
really special time so i want to thank
all of you for coming
[Applause]
and then
we'll adjourn uh because there goes
wendy and jamie uh
talk among yourselves talk to us uh by
uh david's book uh members of the
historical society i know you're out
there uh you buy it tonight just for you
because we've had such a great go i'll
give you one i don't know
20 off special tonight if you're not a
member my staff can totally take care of
you
on
that omission
anyway uh thanks from all of us here and
good night
[Applause]
[Music]